foreign
[Music]
hello dear fans we hope you all had a
good start into the new year 2023 and of
course we are looking forward to
providing you with our Originals again
each week just a couple of weeks ago we
presented you a video about our
superhero highlights of 2023 and 2024.
today we're looking into movies that are
even further in the future but that we
are still very much excited for of
course in addition to the very big
franchises there are also a few new
titles that hardly anyone had thought of
anyway enough of introductions enjoy our
new preview
Sony's Marvel Universe continues to grow
in 2024 after Venom morbius and the
future Craven the hunter El muerto will
be next nothing is known about the plot
yet so we can only take the comics for
reference in these the young wrestler
Juan Carlos Estrada must prove himself
as he wants to claim the legendary title
El muerto for himself he is trained by
his father in The Art of Lucha Libre in
order to become El muerto he must defeat
the mysterious El Dorado after a number
of setbacks he joins forces with
Spider-Man trained with him and finally
faces the villain to what extent the
movie will be based on the comics though
is completely unclear so far the only
thing that is for sure is the casting of
the wrestling superhero Hugh be embodied
by the Latino rapper Bad Bunny the film
was released on January 12 2024.
Captain America 4 New World Order will
be the first Standalone movie of Sam
Wilson AKA Falcon AKA Captain America to
be released in theaters the series
Falcon and the Winter Soldier has
already given us one or two Clues as to
what the plot and the bad guys might
look like in addition to CIA man Joaquin
Torres we will also see former super
soldier Isaiah Bradley again there will
also be another branching out into the
X-Men as Sabra will be a new Mutant
introduced into the MCU nothing is known
about the villain yet but there are some
theories in fandom circles some think
that the Red Skull could return yet
others assume that John Walker may also
play a part again until we know more
some time will pass as of now the film
won't hit theaters until May 3rd 2024.
by the way the premiere will take place
10 years in one month after Captain
America 2 the Winter Soldier we wonder
if that's a coincidence
Sony's most successful Spider-Man
project to date is also getting a sequel
namely Madame Webb the story is about
the same named main character who can
see into the future of all the people in
the spider-verse the new super heroine
is played by Dakota Johnson which
suggests that this is a younger version
of the Spider Woman in the comics as
readers among you know she is already
very old and can barely move from her
spider throat in general the film has a
strong female cast besides Johnson
Sydney Sweeney Emma Roberts Isabella
Merced and Sasha Mamet also play key
roles there are no first pictures from
the set yet but the actresses have
already been seen shooting in New York
sadly without their superhero costumes
the premiere is still just over a year
away so we can possibly look forward to
a first trailer in the summer the
character is generally one of the most
interesting new additions to Sony's
Spider-Man universe as it paves the way
for all sorts of crossovers if nothing
changes we can expect to watch the
Spider Woman on the big screen from
February 16 2024.
fans have had to wait a long time for
the return of Miles Morales in
Spider-Man across the spider-verse as
their almost five years between the
first and the second movie so that we
don't have to wait until 2028 to see the
next film the makers have already
started production on the third part
this means that we can see the sequel to
Miles and the others in cinemas as early
as March 29 2024. obviously we are not
able to say much about the plot yet
since the second part will only be
released on June 2nd 2023 however you
could be sure that we will always keep
you up to date in our weekly news and
Originals as soon as any new details are
known for us the film is already an
absolute highlight in 2024
with Deadpool Venom and Loki Marvel has
had three popular anti-heroes in its
franchise but the MCU is still missing
is a counterpart to DC's The Suicide
Squad and that will hit theaters in
2024. we are talking about the
Thunderbolts which are also the
conclusion of Phase 5 of the MCU the
group consists of six members and all of
them have already made their first
appearance in the MCU the Thunderbolts
are led by Valentina Allegra de Fontaine
played by Julia Louis-Dreyfus she made
her first appearance in Falcon and the
Winter Soldier where she also recruited
the second member namely Wyatt Russell
as John Walker his then adversary and
Captain America Ally Bucky Barnes is
also part of the group a black widow
will also join the chaotic team namely
Natasha's sister Yelena bolova we last
Saw Elena in Hawkeye where she sought
revenge on Clint Barton blaming him for
Natasha's death also her foster father
Red Guardian is involved we can
therefore expect a fair amount of humor
as well and while they had to fight her
in Black Widow Taskmaster the antagonist
from the Standalone film about Natasha
Romanov is another Ally and as the last
member we can welcome ghost which we
already know from Ant-Man and the WASP
recast is the role of General Ross since
the previous actor William Hurt sadly
passed away in 2022 his role will be
played by none other than Harrison Ford
Thunderbolts is scheduled to hit
theaters on July 26 2024
while the dceu has often been the
subject of criticism in recent years and
Marvel has taken the credit with its MCU
Werner has been able to stand by one
thing the independent solo films such as
the Batman or the film Joker which was
released in 2019 especially Joker with
Joaquin Phoenix achieved a great success
not only among fans of typical action
superhero movies five years after the
first film Arthur Fleck now gets his
second big appearance with Joker felia
do this time the plot will be a little
different the movie is to be a musical
which is an interesting decision if we
may say so the film from 2019 was
already convincing not only with its
story but also with the background music
of the scenes as it was not for nothing
that it won the Oscar in the category of
best film score a new addition to the
cast is also confirmed as the role of
Harley Quinn will find its way into the
storyline with Lady Gaga we are very
curious to see how the sequel to Joker
will turn out since the first film set
pretty high standards you can watch
Joker Folia do starting on October 4th
2024
it was probably the biggest announcement
among superhero and comic book fans in
2022 and since then the hype hasn't let
up what is meant of course is the return
of Hugh Jackman as Wolverine and not in
an X-Men movie but with his long-term
rival Deadpool for this the two actors
have made a special announcement video
which went live in Autumn but how did
this actually come about after all
Jackman did say after Logan that his
character was done well the answer is
simple fellow actor Ryan Reynolds is
said to have simply kept bugging him
over and over about the two of them
going back in front of the camera for
another movie thankfully as we can tell
from the eyes of fans a proper Deadpool
and Wolverine movie is definitely
something we've all been eagerly waiting
for the first phase six film of the MCU
can be enjoyed from November 8th 2024
and for us it is one of the ultimate
highlights
in the year 2025 superhero movies will
continue to be a Hot Topic at last one
group makes it into the MCU which has
already had a few attempts on the big
screen the talk is of the Fantastic Four
they were already teased in Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
when the Illuminati made their
appearance there Mr Fantastic was played
by John Krasinski whether he would be
back for the next Solo movie is not yet
known also at this time we don't know
who will be playing Invisible Woman the
Human Torch and the thing we hope the
movie will live up to the standards of
the MCU and that these superheroes will
be a reinforcement for the upcoming
Avengers we expect to see the
superheroes in action from February 14
2025.
in 2025 the time will finally come when
we can see a new Avengers crew on the
big screen it will be six years since
Iron Man Captain America and the likes
finished off Thanos once and for all
it's clear that the superhero group will
undergo major changes quite a few have
died and one or two have retired
nevertheless the new Avengers will
probably have to face an even greater
challenge that of Kang the Conqueror the
latter made his debut in a slightly
different form in the series Loki and
will take on a crucial role in Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania we are already
looking forward to all the news we will
get about this movie in the next few
years the majority of Marvel fans will
then most likely rush to the cinemas in
time for the premiere on May 2nd 2025.
Avengers Secret Wars is the soul
officially confirmed superhero project
for 2026 however the schedule still
includes many Untitled films from the
dceu MCU and Sony about which we will
certainly receive more information in
the coming months in addition to these
films there will of course also be
plenty of series on Disney plus and the
like which will advance the storyline of
some of the franchises
that's it for our second part of our
preview of the most exciting superhero
movies in the coming years which movie
are you looking forward to the most and
which superhero or villain should
definitely become the subject of a
feature film in the future let us know
in the comments and if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up thanks
for watching
foreign
[Music]